salut aujourd'hui je suis avec victor
dérange c'est un vecteur salut salut
fabien aurait super compositeur
interprète auteur ça fait bien et il
fait de la maçonnerie à côte tous les
week-ends quand il est venu faire un mur
et qu'il avait sa guitare j'ai dit
faisons une vidéo exactement exactement
attends je vais me reprocher waouh
là je suis bien je suis au top poitiers
que c'était faux seins faux cheveux j'ai
quand même réfléchir à ce qu'on pouvait
faire ensemble ce que j'aimerais c'est
que tu penses dans ta tête à une chanson
connue si possible chanson française
d'accord et tu penses à cette chanson là
tu me le dis pas ok tu me dis quand
c'est bon trouvé trouvé super
alors je vais utiliser la guitare pour
essayer de retrouver impossible j'ai une
bonne culture de la chanson française
et comme je t'ai demandé quelque chose
que tout le monde connaît en temps
normal je suis senti la connaître on est
d'accord tu es censé la couenne être
obligé alors je vais essayer de lâcher
des notes sur sur la chanson toi t'es
pas obligé de penser au début de la
chanson voilà pense en tout cas ce qui
est le plus connu au général c'est les
refrains gnagra dans ta tête tu me
valide mentalement si j'ai bon pas
draguer tu peux te dire ah oui tiens ça
on dirait un peu le début où ça pas du
tout je vais essayer comme ça de gratter
note à note j'ai jamais fait ça c'est un
peu ce que je fais avec les lettres d'un
mot en temps normal il est où vous allez
et puis là je me demande je me suis
embarquée
non
this past et garder tout moi je veux
dire you either pokerface excellent soit
je fais n'importe c'est énorme à une
petite réaction là vous avez vu il
applique
il ya eu juste un petit truc là dessus
s'y trouve impressionnant c'est de
partir sur des choses je laisse rien
transmettre tout à fait ok c'est
qu'après faut que j'associe avec les
possibilités que ça engendre et on a
plus récemment dans une vidéo avec le la
du mini que les mêmes accords pourrait
couvrir plein de chansons
oh
une espèce de progression qui est en
fait je le vois en attente d'une
progression j'attends de trouver une
mélodie tu vois de me raccrocher à un
truc tintintin parle ça un peu on dirait
qu'on parle un peu plus lointain
où
ah non c'est pas possible de poisson je
sais même pas ce que je joue là mais
apparemment j'ai très bon hockey
[ __ ] alors qu'est ce que je veux faire
et c'est vraiment moche parce que
vraiment il le sait pas là je me répète
mais il croit
ah [ __ ] je sais je te dirais les na na
nana na na examen c'est ça qui a poussé
les meubles eu exactement mal je te
félicite parce que dans ma temps c'est
un truc où je crois que c'est le seul
moment que je connais la chanson c'est
ça le chat tu dirais les bananes et 1
500 noms 500 à temps bon alors par
contre je suppose que je les massacrer
ben non pas tant que ça c'est vrai donc
c'est vrai ce que toi tu pourrais nous
faire voir ce que c'est les mots bleus
ah oui le médiateur du médiator
ce giro
nommé
il
d
un jeu
non
là
et
on
alors là bravo bravo à toi j'adore ta
voix mais j'adore ton style merci et
sans style vestimentaire que je vais
vous faire voir tout de suite parce que
là vous dites oil mec qui est classique
petit polo rouge
petit à petit aux blancs mais regardez
le bas you rock and roll leclerc comment
s'appelle tâche n victor cette victoire
par ange elle s'appelle barange classe
n'appelle pas arrange toi et rejouer à
ra ng eux comme ça se prononce
vous pouvez cliquer ici directement sur
cette tête pour accéder à la chaîne de
bars anges
vous pouvez aussi regarder le bien que
je vais mettre dans le descriptif moi
c'est une chaîne que je suis depuis un
petit moment tu as en abonnés et il en
mériterait plus que moi donc je compte
sur vous pour aller au moins visité la
chaîne
et si vous qui fait abonnez vous
vraiment merci en tout cas à vous
d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si ça vous a
plu n'hésitez pas à la gratifier d'un
léger sensible mais musicale pouce en
l'air vous pouvez également nous lâcher
un petit comme parce qu'on aime ça et
que les vite tous et pensez à vous
abonner avant de partir puisque je vous
rappelle quand même que le mental box et
vidéos par jour pendant un an donc
rendez vous demain à 17h chaud ici
non le square les flammes
c
qui va sentir
je sois jeu
m
faudra bien
il
lui dira
du
m
et ce jeu
le silence il
elle est mon bleu
ce qui rend 2
parler me sens ridicule
on sait depuis
allez on
thierry rey
you